[Music]
Welcome everyone. Uh my name is Mason
Edgar. I work at Temporal and today
we're going to talk about uh events are
the wrong abstraction for your AI
agents. So uh who here raise of hands
recognizes what this diagram is out of
curiosity. Okay. So this is a map of our
solar system um in a geocentric
projection. Uh this is where we have
earth as the center of our solar system
and this is how celestial objects move
around the earth. And this was used to
kind of calculate uh celestial
trajectories prior to like the 16th 17th
century. Um it's really pretty. I really
like it. Uh complex but really nice. And
then around the 16th century uh
capernicus decided to put the sun at the
center of the of the solar system and it
greatly simplified how we view our world
and how we view the universe. Um this
allowed people to start thinking about
the laws of nature. We got the laws of
gravity and the law a lot of different
things because of us being able to
reenter our focus on how we look at the
way that we looking at things uh the way
that we uh build things. And basically a
whole series of new uh discoveries and
developments were made simply by just
focusing our shift on how we decide to
look at things. Now it's interesting to
note that both of these are actually
accurate. They're both correct. Um
however it's interesting that you have
to take the right frame of mind and look
at what do you need to use, what tools
do you need to use, what software are
you using and determine how do we want
to use this as a reference. So, for
example, if we're looking at something
like a moon trajectory, it might be
useful to use the Earth as the frame of
reference here. But if you're thinking
about something as like the planets and
how planetary objects move, then it's
probably more useful to put the sun at
the center of your ecosystem. So, you're
probably wondering why I'm talking about
this, and it's a pro valid question.
We're all building software here. We're
all building AI software, and ensuring
that the software is available and
scalable for our users is extremely
challenging. Um, scaling our AI agents
is actually no different than scaling a
micros service architecture. At the end
of the day, this is all just distributed
systems. Um, which is great because
we're not solving any new problems here.
We're solving the same problem that
we've been solving for the last 20
years. Um, nothing here is new. It's
this. All we did is we added a different
label to it. Um, and we do have patterns
for design for solving this, which is
event- driven architecture. So, I asked
Claude this morning to give me a
definition of what is event- driven
architecture. And this is what it came
up with. It said event- driven
architecture is a software design
pattern where components communicate by
producing and consuming events allowing
for loose coupling and asynchronous
processing where systems react to state
changes or occurrences rather than
direct method calls. Um that's a pretty
fair uh thing and I expect Claude to get
that right. So that's a pretty good
explanation of it. Um but let's look at
say what an event- driven AI
architecture would potentially look
like. So we have pretty fairly decent
design if I do say so myself. I didn't
make this. So if it's great, I made it.
If it's not, blame some blame my
colleague. Um, so we have some cron jobs
here to handle inactive chat sessions,
basically acting as a garbage collector
for a whole bunch of things. We uh have
a message bus where events can be
published and ingested by the various
tools that we are using, different LLMs,
all of those things. Um, we have a dead
letter cue for handling tasks that have
failed and we just cannot possibly
reprocess them. Um, this is pretty
great. This is a pretty straightforward
uh EDA based eco uh architecture. The
question is though, how much of this in
here is actually the core business logic
of your application? How much of this is
actually what we're trying to solve
versus trying to make sure that the darn
thing doesn't break?
Good question. So, some of you might be
going, "Hey, this is great. Ship it.
Love it." Um, and you're right, that
diagram does work. There are probably
hundreds of thousands of agents deployed
into production right now that use that
exact same architecture. And I'm not
going to argue it's a great fine
architecture. It works. But I want to go
back to our discussion that we were
having earlier. Do we have the right
thing at the center of our e of our of
our ecosystem? Are we looking at this
through the right frame of mind? And I'm
here to say that I don't think we do. Um
we have built all of our applications in
the modern world with events as the
center of our universe instead of the
core logic, the core foundation of what
we're trying to solve. Um and if you
look at that diagram that I previously
had, there are more parts about handling
the events than there was the core logic
of the actual application. Uh I was an S
sur in a past life uh for a company and
I've seen applications with hundred
lines of code dead simple logic that
have brought entire enterprises down
large traveling industries that begin
with the letter E um because of
mismanaged cues. So find me after the
talk I'll tell you about my horror
stories. So issues with this approach.
So what do we have? Well we don't get
APIs in an EDA architecture. we
sacrifice clear well- definfined APIs uh
because when we adopt events uh the
events lack documentation and structure
that all of our APIs that we've spent
all these years building have given us
um and yes there is an async API spec
but that really discusses the formats of
the messages it's not really an API it's
just what is produced and what is
consumed it doesn't really give us much
more than that and as we all know
developers are great at documentation
that's why there's so many of y'all
working on documentation AI tooling
right now
um so this is great right then Now we
have scattered logic. Um we have our
business logic now becomes fragmented
and spread out across thousands of
different services. Um instead of having
a bug and let me going oh let me open
the file and see what that is. Now I
have to open multiple files. Now I have
to gp across the codebase for the event
name to figure out who called what when
and where and how. Um and if it gets
even worse I have to run the thing to
figure out how it failed. That's worst
case scenario but I've seen it happen.
It's like I have no idea what this is
doing but if I run it I can figure it
out. And I'm like, that's that's like
saying, we don't know if the car is
going to break when we crash it, so
let's just slam it into the wall and see
what happens. Not a great way to go
about things. Um, and now every single
one of our services is now an ad hoc
state machine. Like, and I know that CS
majors love implementing state machines,
and I'll tell you this, the only reason
they love them so much is because
they've never been paged for one. Uh,
once you get paged for one, you stop
loving your state machines really quick.
Um, services now have local databases
and local caches to make sure that
things aren't failing. Um, in many cases
there's no transactions between the
message and when you've updated your
state. So, you get into this really fun
state where we've updated something, but
we haven't quite actually updated it
yet. And now we've got into this weird
case. And that leads us to the best case
of all, race conditions. So, now we
don't know what's actually happening.
Um, and now we get paged at 2 am in the
morning to to deal with the hardest bugs
of all. Um, and we now either have to
write log to do this or we can do what
some companies do and we can just push
it off to customer success and be like,
"Oh, we'll just reset the system
whenever it crashes. That'll work,
right? We'll just roll back the
database." Um, I don't think that's a
good good thing. All in all, I could go
on and hours and hours about why this
approach doesn't work. But it leads to
one thing, and I'm going to ruffle some
feathers, so we'll do this lightly.
EDA is a tightly coupled system. Now, I
know everyone's going to go,
"Tightlightly coupled? Whoa." We've been
told that event- driven architectures
are loosely coupled. It's what I taught
in school. It's what Claude told me this
morning when I asked it. And it is true.
They are they are loosely coupled, but
they're loosely coupled at runtime. They
are not loosely coupled at design time.
We conflate the two. They think that
because they're loosely coupled, because
we can have a service go down and that
the other services can keep running,
that they are loosely coupled at
runtime, that that translates into
design time. And that is not the case.
That is not how this works. Um, so
imagine that we had this re this
discussion. Engineer A comes up and
says, "Hey, I've refactored all the code
to make everything more loosely
coupled." And you go, "Wow, that's
great. How did you do it?" Well, I
turned all of my local variables into
global variables. Oh, great. Uh, why on
earth did you do that? Well, now we can
add new code and everybody can just read
from them and we don't have to worry
about telling anybody when we update it.
That sounds insane, right? That's what
we do with events. So, I that's what's
happening. So, it's just wild that we
think that that's a good use case. And
it sounds like it's the same logic. Um,
and we can just read from that event
until somebody decides to change the
format because you were reading from an
event that you didn't somebody didn't
know you were. And now somebody else
downstream from you three stories you
didn't know were reading your event
broke you broke their system because you
updated the event. And I can hear
people's pages going off as I'm saying
this. Like been there, done that. Um,
and what it does is it leads to people
not being willing to iterate on their
architecture or their design because
they're scared if they touch the magic
event everything will crumble to the
ground. So this is what basically
happens. So so now what where do we go?
I propose we need to reorient ourselves.
We need to f take a step back and go is
this the actual proper center? Take a
step back and see what the frame is. So
let's put the right thing at the center.
I believe this is durable execution. So
what is durable execution? It's kind of
a new category of software. It's called
crash proof execution. Um, and basically
it enables developers to write software
with less effort. Um, it allows them to
focus on the application on what the
application should achieve instead of
trying to anticipate or mitigate
everything that could possibly go wrong.
This in turn will accelerate your
development and basically it turns out
that failures are inevitable but durable
execution makes them inconsequential. So
here's the four characteristics that
we've come up with to define durable
execution. durable execution
applications automatically preser
preserve your application state. So in a
typical application uh a crash causes uh
causes the variable like a crash will
cause you to lose all your variable
state. Everything is lost and developers
will typically make a cache, a Reddit
cache, a local database, something of
that nature to save all this backup to
so that way we can rebuild the state if
it crashes. In Duro, in a durable
execution system, you automatically get
the saving of the state like for like
out of the box just automatically. All
your local variables, all of your
function calls, the inputs, outputs,
returns, all of it is stored
automatically for you. Because of this,
this allows us to virtualize the
execution. So execution usually takes
place in a single process on a single
machine. and will and basically will
immediately end if that process crashes
for any certain reason. Um, durable
execution can happen across a series of
processes across multiple machines. If
one of the current process fails,
durable execution will basically take
that state that it saved, restart the
execution and resume execution from the
point of the last known good last known
save point and continue on very often
without this ever even being aware the
developer being aware that this even
happened. This is also not limited by
time because durable execution can
survive a crash. it enables it to run
for as long as you like. Um, so it's,
you know, most people would never even
think about putting sleep for 30 days
inside your code. That's a totally valid
and 100% achievable goal within a
durable execution system because it just
comes back online whenever it's ready to
be run. It will survive that crash. I
can sleep for 30 days. If it crashes,
doesn't matter. Bring it back online,
resume the timer, continue forward. And
it's hardware agnostic. We in the in the
past have tried to solve some of these
problems with fault tolerant hardware.
We pay a lot of money to be able to hot
swap out our CPUs, to be able to hot
swap out memory, all of that stuff.
Durable execution is completely hardware
agnostic. It can run anywhere. We ran it
on a Raspberry Pi and shipped it into
outer space. Check out our YouTube
channel. Um you can run it wherever you
want to run it. Uh it's builds
reliability into the software side, not
the hardware side. And it requires no
actual specific hardware. Um and it runs
natively anywhere. And it overcomes all
of these issues. So this is what a
durable execution agent architecture
would look like. We have the still have
our chat UI. We have a durable workflow.
We automatically get retries whenever a
failure happens. When we're talking out
to our LLMs, we're talking out to our
tools. If a if if the LLM goes down,
we're getting rate limit automatic
retries. You don't even have to develop
that. You call a function call, that
function will automatically retry until
that thing becomes successful. Doesn't
matter if this thing crashes in the
middle of it, automatically reconstructs
the state, continues on as if this had
never happened. uh we can store our our
longer states for for storage for audit
purposes at a at a predefined time or
whenever we decide we want to close the
execution. Um
this is basically a much simpler diagram
than what we had earlier. And now the
developer doesn't have to focus at all
about managing cues or events or any of
those things. They can focus solely on
the business logic. So temporal
uh provides durable execution. It's an
open source MIT licensed product. Um
we're here at the at the booth today uh
or in the hall and you can come and
visit us and it supports currently seven
uh programming language SDKs. Uh so Go
Python, TypeScript, Ruby, Net, Java, and
PHP. There will be another one coming
later this year. If you looked into it,
it's not that hard to figure out which
one it is. Um and the interesting thing
about durable execution is all of these
are natively polyglot. So I can call a
function written in Ruby uh from a code
written in Go with basically just
providing it the function name and the
input parameters. Because here's the
dirty secret. It's still events under
the hood. But what did we why why is
this a thing? We've abstracted the
complexities away from the platform
layer. Software engineering as a as a
vocation as a history. If you look back
over the 50 years, 50 60 70 years
software engineering has existed. We go
back to uh you know 1950s. We have made
most of our advancements in programming
languages. Um as we have abstracted away
the complexities away from the
programmer and into into like into the
programming language. None of us are
sitting here writing assembly code
anymore thankfully. I mean some of you
might be and good on you. I'm not. Um
forrand gave us mathematical operations.
We don't have to write assembly language
anymore and store things manually in
registers. Algo 60 and Pascal gave us if
then else structure and structure flow
concepts. We're not writing go-tos and
jumps in our code anymore. Lisp gives us
memory management and garbage
collection. Simula and small talk gave
us object-oriented programming. And this
just continues on and on. We've
continually abstracted away complexity.
Durable execution is the next is the
next foray into this. We are abstracting
away events and the complexity of events
into the software layer and removing
that from anyone having to worry about
it. So you no longer have to worry about
your cues or any of that stuff. And I
leave you with a meme.
So all AI is just distributed systems
under the hood. If you if you are
calling out to if you're calling out
across the network, you're a distributed
system and you basically need to to
handle that. If you want to come and
learn more, um, Temporal is in the
hallway or in the booth, uh, sorry, in
the expo hall. I will be there for
literally as soon as this talk is over.
So, you're welcome to come by. We have
an a, uh, an a durable agent running
demo. Come by, try to break my demo. Try
try turn off my computer, turn off my
laptop. I guarantee you it'll still keep
running when it when it's done. I'll
show you how all of this works. You can
also chat with me in Slack. Uh, we have
a community Slack channel and we have a
newsletter if you're interested. Uh,
thank you very much.
[Music]